hélène darroze est une chef qui n'est
pas du genre à garder pour elle ce
qu'elle pense prodige de la cuisine elle
participe notamment à l'émission top
chef sur m6 et s'affiche dans la presse
pour parler cuisine mais cette fois ci
elle a décidé de répondre à une
interview non pas pour donner son avis
sur un plat mais pour donner son avis
sur ses petits camarades
en effet en plein coronavirus nombreux
sont les people qui font preuve de
solidarité
si certains le font de leur côté
d'autres le font savoir et c'est
précisément ça qui agace profondément
hélène darroze dans une interview à télé
star elle explique être remonté contre
les chefs qui profiterait de la pandémie
pour faire parler d'eux tant que c'est
une initiative qui n'est pas là pour
nourrir le buzz moi ça me convient que
certains en profitent pour se montrer ça
m'horripile une chef engagé qui le
glisse au passage de mon côté ça fait
longtemps que je m'implique dans
l'humanitaire mais je n'en parle pas car
je me suis pas du genre à fanfaronner
on ne sait pas exactement contre qui
cette attaque est dirigée mais le moins
que l'on puisse dire c'est que depuis le
début du confinement
les chefs sont nombreux à avoir pris la
parole pour faire part de la crise sans
précédent à laquelle doivent faire face
les restaurants parmi eux on retrouve
par exemple philippe etchebest et michel
sarran deux collègues de top chef mais
aussi cyril lignac depuis quelques
semaines sa fille chaque soir sur m6 en
solidarité avec les français pour leur
proposer en direct des recettes depuis
sa cuisine
une chose est sûre ces déclarations ne
vont pas plaire à tout le monde alors
mon benji le forcené on va voir son avis
dans un instant moi je vais dire et
redire la vérité je suis un petit peu
d'accord avec hélène darroze je vous dis
la vérité
voilà après vous allez me dire ce que
vous en pensez rené ça va les crottes de
zen merci valait vraiment vraiment au
sérum on répond je me suis trompé merci
raymond madore très certainement mais
malgré tout trois pour moi ce sera quand
même un coup de coeur pour tous ces
chefs peu importe qui se font de la pub
et pourquoi pas c'est pas grave
le principal s'il sait qu'au bout le
personnel hospitalier c'est qu'au bout
l'hôpital eh bien on leur donne les
choses on leur donne à manger etc
peu importe c'est de la com du m'en
fiche on a fait le même procès aux
[ __ ] en dix ans ils viennent chanter
se faire de la pub etc
je m'en fiche au réseau le résultat
c'est quoi ces cas-là francs j'ai des
gens qui peuvent manger et là c'est la
même chose pour l'autre
donc peu importe ce n'est que le petit
vol
le principal c'est qu'au bout de votre
course au bout de la chaîne
l'hôpital a eu lieu des soignants et des
tas et
ce soit toi bats on s'en fiche comme pas
cru bon sens alors oui rené we run et
valérie savard se rend compte que tout à
l'heure il y avait jean luc lahaye hier
l'interview qu'il avait rien à voir
c'est aujourd'hui on ne la gueule et
quand même fou parce qu'on a dit les
people il va me connais double volet gap
et là il y aller mais ils profitent de
leur notoriété sur un jeu bien aimé ses
biens et à pissila dans les moyens pour
que ceux qui critiquent ces gens qui
font ça ils aiment pas les moyens de le
faire on l'est ce que les moyens de le
faire ne rend des services à la
population
oz soit bien mais tout parce qu'il n'y a
que des gens comme ça tu peux que les
moyens de faire kiffer regarde-toi final
c'est pas des barrettes de rempailleur à
biarritz retrouve là c'est pas tous les
jours tous les jours enfin hôpital
exactement vous relier mais c'est vrai
tu le dis aimer c'est normal de l'aïd
atteint qui te sert de terreau notoriété
pour faire du bio jacques calais broyé
et ceux qui critiquent ils sont jaloux
ils critiquent tout alors que t2 est là
et cadets des conneries on dit aux
critiques il est déjà connue bien parce
que bien sûr il la publicité ça va les
couilles le cantal qui font du bien
bonsoir vous lui apprenez en tout cas
françois remercie d'être là je conçois
rené on vous écoutera tous à leur mercie
danger non je voulais un truc énorme et
vous je veux garder pour moi important
dans ces terres du rena version badgée
pas le forcené
bon bah non mais je rappelle quand même
parce que non je voulais dire excusez le
belge et d'un bon c'est le forcené ouais
c'est bel et dabo il ne dira pas parce
que voilà il y des comme ça mais cyril
vous ne savez pas le nombre de gens qui
l'aident et le nombre d'associations
acquis de l'argent les ondes de vente
qui fait quand il va à des ventes aux
enchères c'est toujours lui qui chante
cherry hill dépenses il a fait beaucoup
beaucoup il n'a pas attendu la crise du
coc vite pour donner donner de l'argent
aux autres et croyez-moi surenchère et
quant à des mecs du psg c'est que il y
bien cirées de mêlée moins que les gars
du pg quand même et pour ce qui est du
football à rodez pour l'association des
enfants pour le paris saint-germain tu
sais l'association tu connais ornée pour
les enfants dorment inféodés
ça va c'était si c'est pour des femmes
femmes camille tu vois là et merci et
benji tu as failli [ __ ] dans la merde
et crowley les antennes n'ont pas la
taille est et benjamin je rappelle en
plus son chéri que c'est moi qui paye
toutes les pensions alimentaires
je sais juste par amour
géraldine maillet là mais là où mes
camarades dans complètement raison c'est
que le faire savoir et totalement
accessoire qui compte c'est de le faire
c'est beaucoup à faire que ne pas le
faire et de toute façon aujourd'hui ce
qui les dispense pour parler du foot
justement il ya plein de joueurs qui
donnent mais alors on va leur dire comme
ils le disent pas on dit ouais ils sont
hyper égoïste ouais c'est des salons en
un mois il pense alors et ambri les
chats donc finalement après ils vont le
dire on dire ouais c'est de la com
attention ils travaillent leur image
c'est cynique ce qui intéressait en fait
peu importe
dites-le donné soyez généreux ça donne
des exemples ça donne une émulation ça
donnait et surtout ça aide les gens et
donc va c'est formidable et je trouve
que hélène darroze finalement elle est
tombée pour le coup comme un cheveu dans
la soupe
parce que finalement il est dit moi
aussi je donne mais je ne fanfaronne pas
mais qu'est ce qu'elle fait elle a qu'a
pas dire qu'elle donne alors à ce moment
là moi j'ai vu moi j'en ai vus j'ai vu
le film moi j'ai vu l'émission un cheveu
sur la soupe est philippe etchebest le
cheveu sur la soupe c'est surtout des
bons vraiment là c'est surtout que ceux
à la base elle dit elle l aime pas les
gens qui font de la médiatisation et qui
est voir quand ils font des et moi je
pose une question et les bars aux cff à
la gagner je sais pas si elle a promis à
la fin film qui a cartonné aussi au nom
de la rose mais juste pour roubaix une
mission que si elle n'était pas elle
autant médiatisé est-ce qu'elle aurait
autant de succès dans ses restaurants et
quand elle va à la télé est-ce que c'est
pas pour être médiatisé aussi locale
elle est contre la médiation on l'a vu
quand il y avait eu l'histoire laeticia
et johnny est ce qu'elle n'était pas
elle aussi dans les trucs people à être
médiatisé aussi quand tu es contre la
médiatisation tu restes dans ta cuisine
tu fan osso buco une omelette et tu vas
pas su renaître la côte à l'est comme ça
tu seras pas médiatisée elle au sens
large de la médiation et la raison les
eaux où c'est chaud il a raison et m'ont
alors avoir ce qu'on pense les
téléspectateurs les chiens vous avez vu
que ce qu'elle est ce qu'elle a fait de
beyoncé en parlant des piles fois ci ce
brouillon il
bilan c'est à la dernièrement fait un
nom de 6 millions de dollars s'il
beyoncé à des organisations américaines
pour lutter contre le coronavirus elle
en a expliqué les raisons sur son site
internet
je vous le dis voilà 6 millions de
dollars voilà donc ça fait partie est ce
que voilà parce qu'on n'a pas eu la vie
de benji mine de rien oui le bébé et la
herray et là on va trouver des cons
qu'ils vont dire avec cette façon à les
milliardaires
donc elle peut donner 6 millions et ben
non excusez moi il faut saluer les
gestes de tous ceux qui donnent que soit
5 euros 10 euros 1000 euros 6 millions
d'euros ça me rend dingue ces discours
là robben j'ai franchement c'est une
route
ouais beyoncé elle a beaucoup d'argent
mais elle fait un chèque de cima à mon
pote à l'examen c'est la foire été
abaissés 90 et 100 millions d'euros donc
moi je trouve ça pas bien alors qu'est
ce qu'on fait on donne pas et on vous
reproche de ne pas donner on vous
donnait on vous reproche d'avoir dit que
vous avez donnée à la chaîne ou un peu
oui on fait chauffer tour on fait des
choses et en plus il ya des tas de gens
qui donne moi j'ai appris ça il ya de ça
mais il ya plein de gens qui n'ont pas
beaucoup d'avions qu'ils donnent aux
hôpitaux qui s'est arrêtée de tomber
tout suspect suspicieux voilà on peut
faire des choses normalement son conte
et on le fasse par intérêt arrêter avec
ça c'est insupportable c'est
insupportable et un jour qu'est ce qui
va se passer
eh ben les gens ils donneront plus ils
vont se barrer on leur dira baril au
parti bah oui son parti
vous leur avez craché dessus et ben
voila moi ça m'énerve bah voilà le
forcené a poussé son il fonctionner là